have you driven cross-country before
have you done that I did that years ago
I used to get those drive away cars we
could someone wanted their car yeah I
did that I have a drive cross-country
was a cheap way to get across the
country and deliver someone's car like
because they pay for gas and all it
seems like a great way to do it I have
done the drive my brother went to school
in Oklahoma so I've driven you know back
and forth to Oklahoma and stuff like
that did you enjoy that I love it yeah I
look I mean it's like this there's
nothing better than ultimate feeling of
freedom and driving down an interstate
or route 66 or whichever way you want to
go and being like that is a nice field
I'm gonna take a piss in that field it's
it's just you just like you do whatever
you want you don't have to go through
airport security you don't take off your
shoes like you're just driving you're
running you're an avocado farmer with a
shotgun right my avocados you're one of
them scooter boys
so Germany adventures when you were
driving around cross country yeah I mean
we there there were definitely
adventures that happened along the road
trip
some of which involved sheriff's cars
but you know it was good we were fun
road trip let's examine that what
happened exactly I'm not allowed to talk
about it are you really not allowed to
talk about it not supposed to talk about
it then let's talk about it you got into
trouble
no no no no no it's called it's called a
talk show not a no show
yeah I still got nothing this sounds bad
no it was great can you give us any
hints at all and then we can read we can
I whip edia this son of they are on we
it was a long time ago it was a
misunderstanding this is me being very
political there's a misunderstanding of
laws and interstate laws vers state laws
and apparently federal laws supersede
state laws I was ugly you know who knew
so let's just say it was a great
learning experience of the legal system
ah that's fantastic
yeah Andy advised me what to do now move
on now stay with it
[Applause]
okay we'd have to spend any time at all
in a facility of any kind yeah I mean
you can't sleep in your car on road
trips did it involve a change of clothes
to the color orange no oh no so it was a
local jail not a County
I'm gonna let this go I'm gonna let this
go but we'll be back oh good I'm gonna
I'm gonna get a remote camera crew and
we're coming to your home yep
once I get to the bottom of this